so Teresa may has finally said she'll go
but it wasn't willingly or honorably it
was because she had no choice
finally she saw what we all knew that is
the leader she's finished let's not
pretend she made any great sacrifice and
saying she'd step down
she knows the only chance of getting her
terrible deal over the line is if she's
gone but it could be too little too late
because if the agreement is in passed
the dream of a new global Britain would
be dead and those arrogant remainer MPs
who have always believed they know
better than the British people will have
won their dirty battle and that's mrs.
Mays fault Parliament is out of control
because she can't control it
she was never up to the job of
delivering brexit but her vanity hurry
get one her intransigence made her cling
on to the very end
she says she's resigning to get her deal
over the line I think she's doing it to
secure her place in history as the PM
who fought for and won brexit but that's
not how history will remember her it'll
be as the woman who turned one of the
greatest countries in the world into an
international laughingstock Carol
there's no question about it she has
done a very bad job in negotiating
brexit 90% of the country now thinks
that Parliament has handles very badly
the government's hand as badly and
actually it's a national humiliation
where we are today in fact this week
we've had Santini Selden a great
political historian say this is the
worst constitutional crisis in 300 years
so we're in a very difficult position
right now and I think the crux of it is
this that we had a very narrow decision
in three years ago this three years ago
very narrow decision seventeen point
four million people voted which we
continue told about people forget that
we've only had three referenda ever on a
nationwide basis in this country and the
first of them in 1975 whether to stay in
the European community do you know what
the result was seventeen point four
million people voted to remain but the
big difference there was that seventeen
point four million
was 2/3 majority so it was a conclusive
decision we now have this very narrow
decision that is divided our country and
we're now stuck in this position and you
touched on this 75% of the House of
Commons and more than 80% of my members
in the House of Lords at the time the
referendum thought the best thing for
the country would be to remain and now
in this position where they've lost the
sense of representative democracy which
has been the heart the cornerstone of
Britain's great democracy for the whole
world looks to and we're caught in this
absolute deadlock now how do we get out
of this but it's even worse than that I
think because I had we had a leader who
was strong who was actually a good
leader leaders are supposed to be able
to inspire people they're supposed to be
able to commit to entice people to fold
and the supposed to be able to persuade
people
this woman has none of those qualities
and you know she should have got me oh
she says now she's resigning for the
good of the party the good of the
country if she cared one jot about this
country
she would have resigned a year ago she
would have she should have resigned
after she lost that election she should
never record it she should have resigned
after that she should have also resigned
last year in checkers when it became
really clear that no one was gonna
support this deal but she has dogged Lee
plow down with this
she hasn't listened to people Karen you
know what you you're closer to it than I
am
she hasn't listened to people she has
surrounded herself with remain as she
has she has sidelined all these levers
well the thing is you can say what a bad
Prime Minister shoots what a hopeless
comes she's been she's the fact that she
doesn't listen the fact that she's
blinkered and stubborn all these
criticisms about her probably absolutely
valid but the reality is more than
anything what is driven driving this is
she is trying to keep the Conservative
Party together the conserved party is
completely broken as is the Labour Party
to be fair but so she's trying to keep
the party before country and what is
driving this is we have a profuse to
accept the result it's not a question of
refusing the result of the referendum is
already three years out of date
there are 2.4 million youngsters two of
my children who are 18 years old since
that date who were not allowed to vote
and now they have it they don't have a
say in their future
Karin does it Nivens Winker my grandson
who's one there's not even one you know
let's move on how do we move on from
where we are now that's what interests
me because as you rightly say she will
step aside we've got a belligerent and I
would it's almost impossible to deal
with DUP who seem to be holding out we
have someone like Jacob Riis morally so
they've got a good argument but Jacob
Riis mangu was a supposedly he was for
it then he was actually trying to get
mrs. Mae out of office Cochran was gonna
vote for it now he's not gonna vote for
it Rachel can you divine the past for me
I mean I think we it doesn't profit any
of us to go back over or to those
amazing mistakes at this point I think
that I need to pick Carol up on one
thing which is I'm not sure it's
entirely clear that Teresa may is going
to go now there are some various hard
stop staging posts which we face I mean
there is April the 12th which is if we
don't get a deal then we go out and
there's may the 22nd if we do get a deal
we go out May 22nd if you Theresa May
doesn't get her deal through she has not
held to her own promise to fall on her
sword because that was the bargain she
made the pact with the devil she made
with the ERG with Boris Johnson and
Jacob Riis mob she bought Jacob Riis
mugs loyalty for only six hours by that
promise to resign which Margaret Beckett
said if she wished they were she was in
the ERG she'd want to see that written
in blood Theresa May has a history of
going back on her word
she is not around for the next stage of
negotiated I think she can be held to
that commitment on face tear we have to
remember that the withdrawal agreement
only covers a very limited portion of
our relationship going forward in the EU
you know Ireland this citizenship and
the money ritual you know limited
nothing has been agreed this with all
agree everyone says get the deal done
get over the line you get over this line
we are now faced with years of
uncertainty because nothing's been
agreed the trade relationship security
space consumer rights
nothing's been agreed and business is
suffering and will continue to suffer
shall I just remind you because this is
farcical what we've been through just to
get to this stage with the ruderal
agreements so on the 15th of January we
had meaningful votes episode 1
I'm calling it the Phantom hope this saw
the government defeated by a majority of
230 against the Prime Minister's deal
then on the 12th of March we had
meaningful vote episode to the return of
the votes this saw the deal feel
defeated priced slightly less
embarrassing 149 votes and then the
Prime Minister promised there would be
meaningful vote episode 3 may strikes
back but has since admitted she doesn't
have enough support to put that to the
comments so that installment has at the
time of recording being postponed may
the force be with her I mean the fast
may the the may be forced not to be with
us I think you know I have to say Carol
I agreed with most of what you said in
terms of just how depressing a situation
we find ourselves in but I do think your
diagnosis is unfair I don't think that
there is another person who could have
delivered this in a fundamentally more
desirable way because this is not a
deliverable what was promised it is not
what was I'm not saying someone could
have done a better job Theresa May as
leader of Legion catastrophic just look
at it not because she's oh come but look
at what remains it's not because she
surrounded herself I remain as I think
that a lot of this reflects the
impossibility of what was promised I
don't think it's impossible she okay she
made lots of promises can we just look
at some of those promise that ship this
is at Lancaster House speech I want this
United Kingdom to emerge from this
period of change stronger fairer more
United and more outward looking than
ever before I want us to be a secure
prosperous tolerant country a magnet for
international talent and a home to the
pioneers and innovators who will shape
the world ahead I want us to be a truly
global Britain the best friend and
neighbor to our European partners but a
country that reaches beyond the borders
of Europe too so that was the promises
she made back then they said they were
they were unequivocal let's just see
what she said the other day and she's
admitting defeat MPs have been unable to
agree on a way to implement the UK's
withdraw
as a result we will now not leave on
time with the deal on the 29th of March
this delay is a matter of great personal
regret for me so far Parliament has done
everything possible to avoid making a
choice motion after motion and amendment
after amendment has been tabled without
Parliament ever deciding what it wants
all MPs have been willing to say is what
they do not want and that's exactly
right and she just summed it up there
it's parlor even this week these
indicative votes all it indicated was
that Parliament still doesn't know what
loop of Romania and pays will not accept
the results of the referendum are doing
everything they can to support it if we
had all been united and getting it
through it would have you can you say
that when the hardcore brexit ears are
the ones who have been most staunchly
against her previous to withdraw
agreement it's reaching for Briggs it's
across that's remain as trying to
sabotage a process it is ERG who have
been absolutely opposed and the people
actually think about this exactly
there's a sky poll we should have a look
at just now and that says is Theresa May
on your side regarding brexit and 51% of
people say no just think that means
either people don't want bright suit and
you know inside or they want to deliver
regs and she can't deliver look the
country all of us all Commons is
understandably utterly fed up to the
back teeth of the whole subject but just
to do a bit more justice than to Theresa
May the new did I think that you know
she has struggled to come up with a deal
which still is on the table that both
met honored the result of the referendum
it will we will leave the EU that's all
you need to know the fact that the Irish
backstop means that we can't be global
Britain for an undetermined period of
time and that we're tied to be a rule
taker is the price you have to pay for
getting what you want now that as I see
it just in the next couple
of weeks I still think that she is going
to drive the Commons to vote for her
deal because I don't think we can have
No Deal the comments has said we can't
it could be legally impossible but Karen
what do people would see what you'll see
I think it's her Deal or No Deal No Deal
is the table we're a deadlock that has
resolved now we talk about global
Britain and I think we can move on to
what I want to talk about it